okay today I'm going to talk to you
about microphones and loudspeakers so
for each one we're going to see what is
actually inside them and how does that
allow them to fulfill their purpose so
first of all a microphone has a
structure that looks a little bit like
this now the whole purpose of our
microphone is to turn pressure from for
example someone's voice into an
electrical current that current can then
be amplified so this is a little bit
what my inside of my microphone looks
like so right now I'm doing a red red
which are showing the coils of wire okay
so this part here this part of the
microphone here is called the diaphragm
now what happens here is when someone
talks or someone sings for example
there's they create sound waves which
hit the diaphragm as it does this this
this whole section moves so a coil of
wire moves within our magnetic field as
we can see this coil is fitted around
this pole of the magnet magnetic field
and we have this pole of the magnetic
field there so whenever we have the
movement of a coil of wire within a
magnetic field
we have the process of electromagnetic
induction that just means that we can
create a current because as the
diaphragm moves the coil of wire moves
within this magnetic field allowing a
current to be established so we start
off with pressure from the air so the
air pressure which causes this to move
and that pressure results in a current
now that signal can then be amplified
and that is exactly how our microphone
works now loudspeakers interestingly
have a kind of
similar structure so let me just draw
one for you right now so again they
involve very similar parts so again we
have our magnets and again we have a
coil of wire but this one is slightly
different like I see to show you in just
a second so again if you see here it
involves a magnetic field but this time
which one to achieve something different
because rather than because rather than
starting off with pressure and ending up
with the current we are going to
actually send the current in in order to
produce that pressure and to produce
those sound waves so how does it work in
order to understand how it works we need
to kind of cast their minds back to
Fleming's left hand rule I've done
another video about this that you can
watch in a bit Fleming's left hand rule
tells us that if we have a magnetic
field so here is our magnetic field
right here and if we have remember
there's a magnetic field which is
established around coils of wire when we
pass current through a wire there's a
magnetic field there as well so when
that happens we produce a force and that
force is what is moving this backwards
and forwards all this is here is a paper
cone now because it's an alternating
current it means that the force is going
to constantly be changing direction
that's what allows this paper cone to
move backwards and forwards to create
vibrations and those vibrations are
going to create the sound waves that are
given off here so whereas in a
microphone we've got electromagnetic
induction here instead we're using the
fact that we've got this magnetic field
from the magnets within the loudspeaker
and the magnetic field that's created in
concentric circles around each one of
these wires in order to produce a force
so this time rather than starting off
pressure and ending up with the currents
we're actually starting off with a
current and alternating current and
we're ending up with pressure and the
pressure which vibrates that paper coin
forwards and backwards like that that is
what causes those sound waves and that
is what people can hear so that is the
structure of a microphone and the
structure of a loudspeaker thank you
very much